here's representative Jim Jordan and he
has been waiting for this for a long
time he is I've had him on the show a
couple times he has been waiting for the
moment he would be able to to grill some
execs on the hunter Biden situation so
the FBI didn't tell you uh that that it
was fake didn't tell you that it was
hacked uh and and Mr Roth did the did
the story violate your policies
in my judgment at the time no it did not
yeah that's what you said said what I
would propose excuse me is you said it
isn't clearly a violation of our hack
materials policy nor is it clearly a
violation of anything else
so I think what a lot of people are
wondering is if it didn't violate your
policies
and they didn't tell you it was fake
didn't tell you it was hacked why'd you
take it down
the company made a decision that found
that it did violate the policy it wasn't
my personal Judgment at the time that it
did but the decision was communicated to
me by my direct supervisor and
ultimately I didn't disagree with it
enough to object it you know you know
what you know what I think happened Mr
Roth I think I think you guys got played
I think you guys wanted to wanted to
take it deep down we saw what but the
chairman put up where you said you know
everyone in the white house isn't as a
fascist I think you guys wanted to be
taken down
I think you meet with these guys every
week we know that's been established in
the Twitter files you had weekly
meetings with Mr Chan and the run-up to
the election they send you all kinds of
emails they send you documents on the
super secret James Bond teleporter you
get information on that
I think you guys wanted to take it down
I think you guys got played by the FBI
so Jim Jordan's doing something pretty
clever here that gets to the heart of
this so the the question did you guys
violate policy well Joel Roth is saying
uh we didn't we didn't violate policy
until until the higher-ups forced me to
do it that's why I don't want to purely
scapegoat this one random guy right I'm
not defending him in any way but who who
is his direct supervisor now if he was
the head of trust and safety I'm
guessing his supervisor might be Jack
the CEO or whoever that is that's the
guy they have to haul in next to figure
this out right because again if it was
the boss man the head supervisor who got
the call from the government then
there's your Smoking Gun so they're
getting close like they actually are
getting close to something again will
anything come up this I have no freaking
idea but we're starting we're starting
to get that puzzle I'm always talking
about man it's starting to the pieces
are coming together and we're starting
to see what actually we've been putting
together here the entire time I also
think Jim Jordan's right that you got
played meaning what he means by that is
you got guys had your own biases you
would have loved to taken the hunter
Biden laptop thing down because you
wanted Joe to get elected you would have
done anything that you wanted to to do
to get Trump out of the White House Etc
you got played meaning once there was
enough
smoke and even though the smoke was not
real but once it was sort of there and
you felt some pressure then you didn't
even have to abide by your own policies
again this this he was the head of trust
and safety he's the one in the email
that Jim Jordan right there is quoting
basically saying it doesn't violate our
policies but there was enough there that
you know they can just kind of push you
in the right way
foreign
[Music]